welcome to this video playing capital G
from the US it's pretty good to feed a
master calcium I'm not sure Ghulam Ali
or something that's not about ghulam ali
is a very good feed master like more
like an I am strength and here's some
regular ah nice to see what I haven't
played him or at least I don't don't
remember playing him so what do we have
here um been only we had been only type
of position he doesn't exchange on d5
I'm just playing normal development
moves and now he closes the position so
I try for a night c4 and and f1 the very
straightforward way to play this is
correct
yeah okay and everything is geared
towards that and I'm attacking d6 so it
makes that makes some sense try and form
Queen g3 now but she basically ignored
or does he want to play Knight e5 now or
this one
mm how to play now maybe Bishop g4 even
now this Bishop is potentially bad so
let's get rid of it I'm also threatening
Bishop d7 now ok so maybe taking with
the rook even on now ok let's not be too
sophisticated here take on c 8 can you
take take on c4 wait let's just take him
this is perfectly all right
so night to d6 he will probably put it
on d6 some way to prevent that I wonder
with d 6 95 or something it's not the
end of the world if he gets the night
down so should be a too concerned but
still would have been nice to prevent it
ok let's cover and cavity fall and 93
was the plan of course
yeah a five I can just take I'm on this
scram mightiest 94 even getting rid of
the Snyder sir it's more important than
any small pawn structure problem if this
double point is not even a problem
mmm take some time maybe he's thinking
about f5 anyway or this one this will
also interesting yup okay don't want to
open the queenside
c3 is an interesting move now for black
intending Nazi form trying to activate
the rook you have the talent to it yeah
I take this chance to secure and to
secure the Queen side
yeah I wonder if firm I made some
mistake here it looks like like it's in
decent shape
not sure this is good but term my idea
is to play Knight g4 Knight g4 you take
now 94 and doesn't really help
yeah like it's in good shape with the
996 always have this you 4.2 to watch
maybe he can consider no I thought a
five actually a5 b5 and the night be 75
or after the capture would be some nice
quick on the bee farm I'm not saying
that this was bad but I was more
thinking about 85 my idea to play Knight
f3 him to come attack a 5 so that he
cannot easily play f5 f5 is the only am
only a poor never left in this position
I can also think about g4g 493 and even
g5 this would be an active wait even to
play okay ma'am this is probably
probably a good choice so G for now is
going to play a 4 then don't want that
so this to deform to e6 to f4 check
mmm yeah this looks strange using the
rookie as a block ADA King may be king
e5 even coming ya need to get active
play here check check
yeah this looks very very uncomfortable
I don't have an idea in this position
ready pawns are very strong maybe look
at 33 I get that in oh I'm lucky lucky
if that this was real time morning check
check check in to check check check
check white foreheads on down that's
just too early in the day for this kind
of scrambles this kind of crap shoot
endings where you just need to move yeah
but I wasn't in bad shape and probably
am probably around here I need to
improve you know F wife it's not it's
just not a good position here here maybe
it shouldn't be it shouldn't be a large
problem really
maybe to see to
mmm I need to get F 1 mg foreign of
course then this is some rather came on
here maybe I don't know night f2 and
some but um yeah this is a good defense
and this is a good defense this is this
is the idea yeah this should be should
be okay for white still still your bit
worse but the shirt should actually hold
this is just too closed let's say here
yeah this looks like white should have
decent chances to defend it was a bit
uncomfortable all the way yeah maybe
maybe this Queenie 6 was also just bad
he has problems with playing at five
ones as long as the Queen's Own yeah
complicated stuff thanks for watching